[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est une femme d'exception
une artiste hors norme hors du moule
hors du cadre pourquoi parce qu'elle
fait partie des quatre tout petit pour
cent de femmes chefs d'orchestre
française parce qu'elle a créé son
propre orchestre symphonique
divertimento et parce qu'elle a tenu à
ce qu'il soit à stains en
seine-saint-denis le département où elle
a grandi là où ses parents se sont
installés quelques temps après leur
arrivée de kabylie aujourd'hui elle se
produit partout dans le monde elle a
dirigé plus de deux mille concerts car
au delà de la musique ce qu'il anime
c'est l'ouverture de l'universel
phonique à tous à tous les publics à
toutes les catégories sociales car
disons le ce n'est toujours pas le cas
d'ailleurs son combat sera-t-il gagner
le jour où elle ne sera plus présentée
comme la femme chef d'orchestre qui
vient de seine-saint-denis eh bien on va
se poser la question avec est bienvenue
dans un monde un regard bienvenue zahia
ziouani et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans ce dom tournon au sénat
c'est vrai que vous êtes encore et
toujours je viens de le faire présentée
comme la femme chef d'orchestre qui
vient de seine-saint-denis est ce que
pour vous ça veut dire que le chemin est
encore long et que le jour on arrêtera
vous présenterez de vous présenter comme
cela c'est que vous aurez gagné votre
combat oui et que je l'aurais gagné à
plusieurs titres parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les femmes on est très
peu présente dans cet univers là et que
on est dans un pays qui a beaucoup
d'inégalités ont été mises en lumière
particulièrement notamment ces derniers
ces derniers mois ces deux dernières
années et que la culture fait aussi
partie de ces sujets qui sont encore
malheureusement trop inégalitaire en
france et que justement il ya beaucoup
de territoires dont certains territoires
urbains la seine-saint-denis des
territoires ruraux aujourd'hui il ya il
ya trop peu de culture etc aujourd'hui
ben moi mon engagement c'est de dire que
tous ces territoires mérite justement
d'avoir accès au même titre que dans les
grands lieux culturels la culture et moi
j'ai envie d'un monde où on fera plus de
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes on fera plus de différence entre
les grandes cultures et les lieux de
proximité et où justement cet excellent
cela cette beauté de la musique et bande
en fera bénéficier à tout le monde
partout alors vous dites ils sont des
territoires où il n'y a pas forcément de
culture il y en a une en l'occurrence
alors elle est peut-être caricatural
mais quand on pense ce seine-saint-denis
on pense effectivement cultures urbaines
hip hop rap r'n'b évidemment on pense
pas forcément musique classique ça veut
dire qu'on a tort ou ce n'est pas
complètement faux non plus
non vous avez tort
alors après je voudrais en effet
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
c'est vrai qu'il ya des territoires où
il n'y a presque pas de culture il y en
a où il y en a où il ya beaucoup de deux
projets qui s'exprime dans le théâtre la
danse bien évidemment les cultures
urbaines et ce sont des esthétiques qui
sont très fortes et qui sont importantes
mais bon on a souvent parfois préjugés
un petit peu de la capacité des jeunes
des habitants de certaines familles à
apprécier aussi la musique classique la
musique symphonique en dix ans
maintenant ils vont pas être intéressé
c'est pas fait pour eux et c'est vrai
que ben la musique fait partie aussi de
notre patrimoine musical la musique
classique et que c'est un univers qui
est beau quand vous êtes en face d'un
orchestre symphonique ça n'a rien à
envier au rock ou à plein d'autres
musiques ça dégage une très belle
énergie est vraiment ces belles émotions
cette énergie tout le monde doit pouvoir
y avoir accès et c'est là où aujourd'hui
je trouve qu'il ya pas assez de d'équité
sur notre territoire est alors comment
ils réagissent ces jeunes à ces
nouvelles musiques pour eux à laquelle
ils n'ont pas auquel ils n'ont pas
forcément accès on va on va entendre
peut-être justement un extrait sain
extraits de casse noisette de
tchaïkovski typiquement comment réagit
style quand ils entendent ça va écouter
très bien moi de fin de mes 25 ans
maintenant de carrière j'ai jamais
entendu j'aime rencontrer un jeune qui
me dit ça m'intéresse pas je veux pas et
c'est pour ça que pour moi cette
rencontre avec laure qu'est cette
rencontre physique elle est très
importante et quand je vais avec mes
musiciens en seine-saint-denis dont les
agglomérations de lyon de grenoble du
mans au milieu rural on part avec la
formation symphonique dans son
intégralité parce que parce qu'aussi
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus beau c'est il
ya beaucoup d'énergie et quand vous êtes
face à un orchestre symphonique ça vous
laisse pas indifférent et c'est après
consultation ont leur change le
peut-être leur regard leur appréhension
et ça se passe toujours très bien mais
moi ce que j'aime bien c'est leur faire
goûter comme on écoute la l'instant un
extrait d'une oeuvre très emblématique
du répertoire classique et puis après
dans un second temps parfois à proposer
des projets artistiques qui vont être
associés avec parfois des cultures
urbaines par mégawatt style de musique
pour simplement montrer qu'aujourd'hui
on peut aussi
jouer les musiques et les interroger
avec des sujets que vous avez un mélange
très audacieux en tête la ba oui par
exemple en ce moment j'ai envie de
parler de ce que je fais en ce moment
qu'il ya autour de camille saint saëns
qu'un compositeur français voilà que
l'on commémore aujourd'hui puisque on
fête les 100 tentes son décès c'est un
compositeur qui fait partie de notre
patrimoine musical français européens
qu'à elle-même était considéré comme
très académique et aujourd'hui moi
j'aime bien présenter ses oeuvres par le
prisme de ses voyages en espagne en
italie en egypte en algérie et de
montrer qu'aujourd'hui certaines de ces
musiques qui font partie intégrante de
notre patrimoine musical ont été aussi
inspiré de cette rencontre avec ces
cultures et un moment où on s'interroge
beaucoup à qu'est ce que c'est d'être
français on parle beaucoup de
communautarisme 2 comment justement de
migrants de migration je trouve ça
important aussi peut-être de rappeler
que notre pays s'est aussi construit de
ses rencontres avec d'autres cultures
et voilà c'est un exemple très concret
comme parfois aussi j'en fais d'autres
où cette année j'aurai l'occasion par
exemple de d'intégrer des danseurs de
breakdance sur des productions de
musique de ballet où d'habitude dans
l'habitude de voir des danseurs
classiques des danseuses classiques va
de dire qu'à partir du moment où une
musique a été écrite où on ressent la
notion du mouvement de la danse et bac
on peut aussi y apposer un style très
contemporain très urbain d'aujourd'hui
vous allez aussi en milieu carcéral je
crois oui comment réagit le public sont
des moments plus fort aussi ou oui alors
plus fort aussi pour nous forcément mais
en fait l'idée c'est vraiment de d'être
présent sur dans les grandes salles de
concert parce que c'est aussi notre
place notions on joue en ligue des
champions s'il veut prendre une analogie
avec le domaine sportif donc voilà notre
place elle aussi là et on n'est pas des
artistes ou un bon os différent c'est
simplement moi mon engagement c'est de
dire il faut plus qu'on fasse de
différence entre les grandes salles de
concert et les autres lieux et
d'apporter la culture là où elle est
moins présente alors plutôt la musique
symphonique là elle est moins présente
parfois dans certains territoires
urbains en milieu rural en milieu
carcéral en milieu hospitalier parfois
même dans le l'entreprise c'est aussi
une façon pouvoir voilà faire découvrir
notre passion pour la musique la
partager et amener même des personnes
des détenus qui voit là on traverse une
période de leur vie compliquée et des
coûts sentais que ça leur fait du bien
mais complètement et ils sont ils nous
demandent à chaque fois
voilà des enregistrements de revenir ils
ont aussi besoin de rêves d'évasion de
rencontrer aussi ce qui a de plus beau
et donc elle amène de la douceur du beau
dans ces endroits la musique laisse à l
amène de la douceur du boël amène aussi
bas aussi la réflexion dont je vous
parle depuis tout à l'heure parce que
moi j'aime bien parler avec le public à
chaque concert que je fais que ce soit
la philharmonie ou en milieu carcéral de
montrer comment justement ces musiques
là elles m'ont aussi fait vibrer l
m'émeuvent comment moi il faut réfléchir
vautorte vous avez un portois la hacker
leur tige envie d'être aujourd'hui au
21ème siècle et moi s'il ya bien une
chose que j'ai envie de partager avec
les publics c'est de montrer que notre
culture le monde de la musique ce n'est
pas une bulle qui a un regard vers le
passé mais qu'aujourd'hui c'est aussi un
lieu de rencontre et de pouvoir
organiser ces rencontres en milieu
carcéral ou ailleurs je trouve ça
fantastique vallée parlez nous de vous
et de votre parcours zahia ziouani
comment vous y venez vous à la musique
c'est par l'intermédiaire d'un
instrument je crois à la guitare d'abord
oui c'est la guitare et c'est avant tout
par mes parents en fait qu'ils étaient
de grands mélomanes et et voilà et qui
depuis qu'on est enfant bébé même on
écoutait de la musique à la maison voilà
on a beaucoup aimé votre soeur ma soeur
jumelle j'ai un frère un peu plus jeunes
aussi donc nous on a toujours bercé dans
un univers très culturelle très musical
on écoutait plein de musiques
différentes mais beaucoup de symboles un
best-of de mozart et je crois qu assez
naturellement par la suite on a voulu
concrétiser salars atik d'un instrument
est pourquoi je sais le d'orchestre
alors parce qu'a priori que pour
quelqu'un qui n'y connaît pas grand
chose que moi je vous cache pas passer
dans son usine où on sort du son il ya
quelque chose de concret qui sort de sa
propre pratique chef d'orchestre c'est
très différent comment vous c'est vrai
après ça s'est fait en plusieurs étapes
alors en effet moi j'ai voulu entrer
dans la musique par la pratique de la
guitare un instrument que j'ai adoré et
mais rapidement comme j'étais pas enfin
mes parents n'étaient pas musicien moi
même je savais page je suis senti un peu
frustré ce que je voulais absolument
jouer les musiques que j'entendais la
maison et je voulais jouer de goût dans
un orchestre jouer les symphonies des
concertos donc j'ai joué un deuxième
instrument l'alto et franchement ça a
été pour moi un déclic parce que c était
immergé dans cet univers de l'orchestré
et de l'alto vous êtes au centre de leur
caisse rentrer les soins aigus les sons
graves au plein coeur de celle de laure
caisse et surtout juste devant le chef
d'orchestre
et moi ce qui m'a fasciné c'était de
voir cette personne qui était là pour
fédérer des musiciens les emmener dans
la même direction créer un son créer une
unité collective et petit à petit je me
suis dit mais c'est ça que j'ai envie en
fait mais qu'est ce qu'on vous dit au
début on vous rient au nez on vous dit
mais maman chérie tu rêves qu'est ce que
vous dites si oui alors oui vient alors
ça c'est sûr que ça j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont dit non non
c'est pas ta place est pas fait pour les
femmes c'est pas fait pour les jeunes
concentre toi sur tes études donc oui
j'en ai eu des messages de découragement
j'ai rencontré des personnes qui m'ont
beaucoup décourager j'en ai rencontré
aussi qui m'ont beaucoup encouragée
voilà toujours sous le regard attentif
et bienveillant de mes parents qui m'ont
toujours aussi inculquer des valeurs de
de force de combativité de travail
d'exigence donc moi j'ai été quelque
part un peu armés pour pour me dire est
ce que j'y vais ou ski j'y vais pas et
puis bon ben voila j'ai eu la chance
aussi de grandir dans une famille où ma
mère ma grand mère c'est des femmes
fortes combatif persévérante met pas de
frein en donnant aux femmes non non mes
parents ont connu la guerre en algérie
donc je me suis dit bon voilà chaque
chacun peut aussi porter ses combats et
je me suis dit je vais pas risquer ma
vie zahia vas-y quoi et donc bah je me
suis quand même lancée et voyant en
effet dans le paysage musical qu'on
laissait peu de place aux femmes peu de
place aux jeunes et que moi même ayant
un parcours atypique
on est en grande île en
seine-saint-denis en me nourrissant de
la double culture je me suis dit emma
zahia il faut que tu te crées toi même
tes propres conditions sinon ça marchera
jamais en fait et ça me donne envie de
vous montrer cette archive alors je vais
vous laisser la découvrir tranquillement
et je vais la décrire pour le public est
en train de nous écouter c'est un
document assez sidérant c'est le
règlement du concours pour le
recrutement de musiciens pour les
orchestres permanent de la radio
diffusion télévision française on est
alors en 1956 et regardez bien dans les
orchestres de paris il est bien spécifié
que sur les dix violon 8 sont réservées
à des candidats masculins quant à l'
orchestre de strasbourg il est écrit
noir sur blanc que pour les cinq alto et
les deux violons les emplois sont
réservés aux candidats masculins
1956 une archive qui nous vient des
archives nationales qui sont nos
partenaires sur cette émission c'est pas
si vieux que ça non c'est pas si vieux
que ça et est en effet pendant très
longtemps les les femmes n'étaient pas
du tout présente dans les orchestres et
même dans certains orchestres en europe
il ya même pas besoin d'aller aussi loin
que 60 70 ans même de ya trente ans les
femmes étaient interdits dans certains
orchestres et les personnes les
musiciens d'origine étrangère et femmes
étaient interdits dans certains
orchestres certains hors caisse donc
c'est vrai que ça montre que c'est un
univers qui a besoin encore de beaucoup
progressé sur justement la place des
femmes s'est il est intéressant ce
document je n'avais jamais je vous le
donne après les mairies
mais en effet c'est ses traits marquants
est forcément du coup si dans les
orchestres on avait si peu de présence
de femmes c'est difficile dans le poste
qui incarne par excellence
l'autorité la prise de décisions bas on
n'accordait pas la confiance aux femmes
est encore aujourd'hui c'est quoi la
meilleure réponse à ça c'est de monter
sur scène et de montrer ce que vous
savez faire et là vous montrer que femme
ou homme vous avez autant votre place
que les autres ça va très sensée à vous
c'est exactement ça c'est montrer
qu'aujourd'hui
moi ce que je ce que je montre ma
réponse est de montrer qu'on est en une
femme et en étant jeune et ben ça n'a
pas été des freins pour même au
contraire ça m'a permis samassa et et
des forces et souvent me dis dis donc
vous avez vous en avez eu des handicaps
pour réussir alors oui c'est sûr que ça
a été beaucoup de freins mais en même
temps c'est ce qui m'a permis d'avoir
aussi des approches différentes un
regard différent une merci vers ans
aussi peut-être plus forte et de me dire
aujourd'hui quelle est la chef
d'orchestre que j'ai envie d'être et
donc moi j'avais envie de à la fois de
de transmettre ce patrimoine avait
beaucoup d'excès lancement maintenant de
l'interroger par rapport à des sujets
d'aujourd'hui moi je n'avais un peu
quelque part je trouvais ça un peu
triste d'aller au concert d'antan des
symphonies mais sans le dire mais en
fait à quoi ça sert dans ton des
symphonies du passé ou qu'on va au
cinéma on va pas forcément que voir des
films qui ont été réalisés il ya 50 ans
donc quel est l'intérêt aujourd'hui de
transmettre ce patrimoine bien sûr qui
c'est important de le faire mais moi
j'avais envie de l'interroger par
rapport à des sujets qui nous concernent
aujourd'hui j'avais envie que moi j'ai
eu la chance de rencontrer la musique
par la famille aujourd'hui un enfant qui
ne peut pas rencontrer la culture et la
musique dans la famille ni même à
l'école nous dans le monde culturel les
artistes on a une responsabilité peut
pas continuer à vivre dans un pays où il
ya autant d'inégalités et que c'est
important de s'emparer de ces sujets là
donc c'est vrai que quelque part le fait
d'avoir rencontré plein de france amené
à travailler différemment réfléchir
différemment et justement à peut-être à
estomper tous ces cloisons mans qui
avait entre eux ont fait du classique et
d'autres styles de musique on joue dans
les grandes salles et on joue dans les
petites salles on est artiste où on est
enseignant moi j'ai au contraire voulu
en faire quelque part une force qui
aujourd'hui fait que je suis toujours
présent paix au coeur du paysage je le
disais en début d'émission 4% seulement
des chefs d'orchestre française sont des
femmes quand on pose la question à
certaines de vos concerts voici ce
qu'elle répond j'ai noté la réponse de
claire gibault que je cite ce sont des
hommes qui sont à la tête des grandes
institutions musicales et donc ils
engagent plus d'hommes que de femmes
parce que c'est leur réseau parce que ce
sont leurs habitudes ça vous semble
juste et ce qu'il faut que ça change il
faut des objectifs de parité par exemple
mais mais c'est tout à fait juste et
parce qu'aujourd'hui si on regarde le
profil des décideurs en france
programmateur au niveau de l'état ou
autre en effet c'est les mêmes profils
d'hommes plutôt entre 50 et 60 ans voilà
plutôt plutôt blanc faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont donc aujourd'hui
tant qu'on n'aura pas et la parité mais
aussi des personnes avec des origines
sociales et culturelles différentes on
aura passé regarde nouveaux on a besoin
dans notre paysage musical donc
aujourd'hui moi je suis assez j'avais
pas forcément cette analyse là il ya
plusieurs années mais aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on ait des moyens d'action très
fort avec en effet pourquoi pas des
quotas comme on l'a fait en politique
avec des critères de respect de de
parité de même de
rayonnement des projets aujourd'hui on
peut pas continuer jeudi de façon très
sereine parfois injecter autant d'argent
dans certains établissements qui n'ont
pas forcément où certains projets
culturels qui n'ont pas assez de
rayonnement plus largement que
simplement quelques fois les abonnés de
ces mêmes établissements vous pensez à
quel établissement après enfin jeunes a
aujourd'hui on en vouloir dénoncer mais
est ce que oui ou non il ya des
dysfonctionnements de cet ordre là c'est
en fait on a la chance de vivre dans un
pays où il ya énormément de très beaux
projets artistiques et culturels en
termes de compétences de n'y a pas de
sujet là dessus par contre parfois on a
peut-être trop eu l'habitude dans
certains grands établissements parisiens
ou même parfois en région de penser
qu'il y avait qu'une seule façon de
faire de la musique c'est à dire de
l'incarner peut-être à l'opéra de paris
ou dans un orchestre en région et est de
dire qu'il n'ya que comme ça qu'on
faisait de la musique au jour oui si
vous aller un peu plus loin voilà en
banlieue parisienne l'autre côté du
périph comme périphérique ou dans les
milieux ruraux les gens n'attendent que
ça aujourd'hui on parle de les salles de
concerts ont du mal à se remplir à quoi
sucre vide moi partout où je vais jouer
les salles sont pleines mais parce que
les gens ont besoin de ça on a envie de
ça et qu'on n'y a pas de présence de ces
institutions là bas les gens sont en
demande donc ce que je veux simplement
dire c'est que parfois il faut peut-être
s'autoriser se motiver un peu plus pour
dire que la culture elle doit aussi
vivre beaucoup plus largement que
simplement dans ces lieux là est ce que
vous le déranger ce milieu de la musique
est ce qu'il ya des certains puristes
qui n'aime pas ce que vous faites ce que
c'est un milieu qui peut avoir aussi un
peu son onze sa fermeture d'esprit et
que là vous vous êtes en train de
bousculer un peu les choses et vous
déranger vous le sentez ou pas très
sincèrement j'espère ne pas déranger ce
milieu j'ai envie plutôt de l'inspirer
il est certain que oui tout le monde ne
partage pas mais position sinon je
serais pas aujourd'hui en train aussi
d'essayer de convaincre que de faire la
culture à stains à sevran à vaulx en
velin c'est pas de la politique de la
ville mais c'est de la culture au même
titre que les concerts que je fais à la
philharmonie de paris est aujourd'hui
encore trop de différences entre ces
territoires là quand je vais jouer
demain je joue a par exemple instinct
concert 5 sens que je vais donner dans
quelques mois la philharmonie de paris
je serai habillé de la même façon on va
jouer les mêmes partitions que qu'on est
pour autant aujourd'hui notre travail
parfois dans certains territoires qu est
assimilé à la politique de la ville et
dans d'autres endroits de la culture
donc forcément aujourd'hui quand
j'exprime ça publiquement ça interroge
peut-être que ça bouscule on à janot n'a
pas envie d'être bousculé dans ses
pratiques moi j'ai juste envie de dire
que on peut pas aujourd'hui parler dans
les politiques publiques d'accès à la
culture d'éducation de relever des
sujets qu'ils sont aussi forts que le
terrorisme le communautarisme face et
des choses qu'il faut aussi interrogé
par plusieurs aspects dont la place de
la culture dans ces territoires là pour
amener les jeunes à s'ouvrir à être
curieux à découvrir le monde part avec
de la qualité avec de la qualité moi ce
que je suis aujourd'hui c'est de faire
découvrir le monde par la musique à la
culture c'est comme ça que justement
luttre contre aussi contre
l'obscurantisme qu'on permet à des
jeunes de s'autoriser de grandes
ambitions d'avoir un esprit critique
abouti et vous vous produisez évidemment
en france on l'a on l'a entendu mais
aussi dans le monde ailleurs dans le
monde dans pas mal de pays est ce qu'à
un pays qui vous tient plus à coeur dans
lequel vous avez joué avec le plus de
joie et d'émotion alors écoutez ça vous
voyez où je veux en venir oui tout à
fait
en fait si la chose en effet beaucoup
voyagé daley d'aller dans des grands
pays de culture comme dans les pays de
l'est la russie l'ukraine dont beaucoup
de pays européens j'ai eu l'occasion de
diriger beaucoup aussi d'autres
orchestres nationaux en france et ça a
été pour moi chaque fois beaucoup de de
plaisir évidemment l'expérience à la
tête de leur caisse nationale d'algérie
elle restera pour moi très marquante
parce que bah pour moi ça a été aussi
pendant six ans presque sept ans une
opportunité aussi de m'impliquer dans le
développement de ce pays dans le
développement culturel qui est aussi le
pays de mes origines donc forcément ça
eu pour moi ça a été très touchant quand
j'étais à régis suis arrivé la première
le premier concert que j'ai donné il y
avait que des hommes dans cet orchestre
petit à petit et parfois ça m'est même
arrivé dans certaines régions d'algérie
de faire des concerts où il y avait que
des hommes dans la salle que des hommes
sur scène la seule femme qui était là
c'était moins tant que chef d'orchestre
et je me dis bon il ya beaucoup de
chemin mais on n'entend quel beau
symbole quel beau message on peut
montrer ça a évolué c'est en train de
bouger ouais c'est en train de bouger
mais parfois les résistances que j'ai
rencontrés n'étaient plus forte en
france que parfois en algérie maintenant
sur tout ce que moi je veux retenir de
cette expérience en algérie et c'est que
j'ai mis en place des coopérations ou
gens j'en ai des musiciens français avec
moi travaillent en algérie j'ai invité
des musiciens algériens à venir en
france ça nous a permis beaucoup
d'échangés aussi et que quand je
dirigeais là-bas en algérie je me
rendais compte que le public avait envie
de d'écouter de la musique classique
européenne et de la musique classique
aussi du monde arabe et que de passer de
l'un à l'autre ça leur posait pas de
sujet en fait je me dis mais tient mais
c'est ça et en fait ça m'a permis un
petit peu de mieux construire ma
stratégie quelque part artistique ma
ligne artistique où j'ai envie de
montrer que ya pas de frontière que la
musique classique elle peut fédérer des
disciplines artistiques différentes et
que justement on peut faire se
rencontrer des univers musicaux très
différents un peu de politique dans ce
que vous faites ou pas oui dans le sens
beau et littéral du terme mais tout à
fait oui après moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est ma
façon de voir les choses pour être chef
d'orchestre faut avoir une vraie vision
politique artistique de savoir pourquoi
je fais ce aimer ce métier là comment
j'ai envie de le faire c'est vrai que au
début quand on a 20 ans imaginez moi je
me suis un peu imaginer faire quatre
fois le tour du monde tous les ans elle
y dirige à new york pékin tokyo et c'est
très bien aussi mais abandonnée je me
suis dit mais il faut aussi que c'est dû
sans cet engagement d'artistes et donc
moi je suis aussi je l'assumé pleinement
une grande chef d'orchestre capable de
jouer les plus grandes oeuvres du
répertoire musical mais j'ai aussi envie
de
partager aussi cette musique là avec des
personnes qui vont dire pour la première
fois au concert de réinterroger notre
musique par rapport à des sujets qui
nous concernent aujourd'hui même si
c'est des oeuvres ont été composés il ya
200 ans il ya cent ans il ya 50 ans j'ai
des photos à vous montrer zahia ziouani
et elles sont censées vous inspirer des
choses
je commence par une une du monde alors
c'est barack obama mais ce n'est pas
tant le sujet c'est plutôt cette une du
monde parce que j'ai lu que vous lisiez
beaucoup le monde et que votre père
lisez lui-même le monde est ce que c'est
vrai ce que j'ai lu des fausses
informations c'est bien vrai nom c'est
bien vrai et mon père
n'a pas eu la chance d'aller à l'école
mais il s'est beaucoup instruit on quand
il est venu en france on écoute en
france culture en lisant le monde en
lisant beaucoup de livres et donc du
coup c'est vrai que il était très voilà
très soucieux que également nous on
puisse
être ouvert à plein de choses et donc
tous les jours on avait chacun notre
petit petit moment de lecture avec lui
si vous avez appris à lire en nivelant
le mans voilà ça je vous cache pas que
je comprenais pas tout tout le temps le
mail en tout cas c'est vrai j'ai même
retrouvé récemment des des lettres que
parce que quand j'avais des exposés à
faire pour l'école du coup j'écrivais au
monde entend envoyer mois des articles
qui pourront et m'aider à faire l'exposé
et a laissé une envie d'adhérer
d'épouser les codes culturels du pays de
la part de votre père il nous a toujours
élevé dans la vraiment le respect de nos
traditions de nos origines mais aussi
avec en disant tiens j'ai fait le choix
de venir en france de faire naître mes
enfants en france de les faire grandir
en france eh ben il faut aussi qu'il
connaît ce qu'il ya de mieux dans cette
culture française qui s'approprie aussi
voilà et moi je me sens mais à dix mille
pour cent français il ya même aucun
sujet là dessus et j'ai un profond une
profond un profond respect et admiration
et attachement à mon pays et à la
république française
j'ai une photo un peu moins
conventionnelles à vous propose de vous
faire sourire je l'expliquais à notre
public donc c'est une photo de la
chanteuse américaine tina turner c'est
sa pochette de 1984 private dancer alors
pourquoi parce que là aussi j'ai lu que
votre père très mélomane aimait beaucoup
tina turner et ils n'écoutaient
évidemment pas que du classique à la
maison c'est vrai aussi c'est vrai aussi
tout à fait et en effet alors même si la
majorité du temps on écoutait beaucoup
de musique classique d'accord on a aussi
beaucoup écouté de musique des chants
kabyles de musique oscille d'algérie
voilà de notre pays mais ce que faisait
il là que vient votre envie de mélange
des monges les univers je pense en tout
cas
le fait d'évoluer dans tous ces univers
musicaux et artistiques différents c'est
qu'en fait on se posait pas la question
passer de l'un à l'autre sans aucune
question sans aucune limite ont aucune
résistance et donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qui m'amène moi
aussi à avoir cette quelque part cette
facilité est ce naturel ajustements à
faire peut-être même se raisonner des
univers musicaux entre eux parce que le
classique a bien sûr aurez vous écoutez
quoi mais franchement à moi j'adore le
jazz j'adore écouter michael jackson
enfin voila c'est des grands nombres
j'adore évidemment voilà le jazz les
musiques latino-américaines
j'écoute aussi beaucoup de
du monde arabe parce qu'aujourd'hui a
besoin aussi de s'inspirer moi j'ai
aussi besoin d'être inspiré par d'autres
choses parce que voilà d'être tous les
jours dans la musique classique dans les
raisonnements les dossiers et tout ça
moi j'ai aussi besoin de m'aérer nourrir
voilà toute chose allez une dernière
photo forest whitaker est un acteur
américain vous connaissez vous
connaissant de soirée alors il a décidé
d'investir en seine saint louis il va
aider les jeunes exactement à se former
à l'entrepreneuriat entre autres il est
allé à la courneuve assez récemment et
il a il dit avoir été très choqué par la
pauvreté du quartier de clichy sous bois
par exemple celtique de deux personnes
dont on a besoin dans les banlieues où
on manque de tout on manque de moyens de
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure à
écouter on a besoin de toutes les forces
qui existent alors après s'il a choisi
de venir s'investir en france c'est
super pour nous parce que voilà c'est
une personne aussi qu'il ya qui suscite
énormément d'admiration cas aussi une
belle expérience de la vie dont on
pourra également profiter et aussi
d'autres réalités aux états unis qui
sont très délicates donc qu'il ait
décidé de s'investir en france moi je
trouve ces traits c'est super et quelque
part il a pas tort bien sûr ça rejoint
peu nos précédents échanges c'est à dire
que on est quand même aujourd'hui en
france au 21ème siècle et où on a des
quartiers en france qui sont voilà très
dépourvu de de moyens en terme de santé
de transport d'entrepreneuriat de et moi
je le vois tous les jours ça vous en
voulez au discours médiatique sur ces
territoires d'en parler toujours d'une
certaine façon et pas de façon positive
ou pas oui après après bon voilà il ya
ceux qui parlent ya ceux qui font partie
de ce qu'ils font est parfois oui ce que
je trouve regrettable c'est con on parle
pas des projets qui ont qui ont du sens
on parle pas aussi des combats de tous
les jours des familles des parents qui
ont vite que leurs enfants réussissent
le ces mêmes jeunes qui qui travaille
très dur pour s'en sortir et qui moi je
le vois au travers de notre académie où
on amène ces jeunes-là par la musique
par l'exigence que demande la pratique
de la musique on les emmène à à dépasser
leurs limites à arrivé même très loin
dans leurs études et puis après une fois
qu'ils y arrivent ils se retrouvent
parfois confronté aussi à ce fameux
plafond de verre où ils ont du mal à
postuler dans des grandes entreprises
ils ont du mal à avoir accès à un
premier logement et donc oui ça ça veut
dire moi je trouve ça dur aujourd'hui je
trouve ça vraiment très dur et est donc
on soit plus dire aujourd'hui que
lorsque vous vous avez essayé de vous
lancer dans la musique classique où des
rixes et presque de plus en plus dur
pour les jeunes des quartiers au oui moi
je trouve en fait je trouve qu'on a ces
derniers temps on a traversé des moments
lieu les émeutes de banlieue il ya eu
les attentats il ya eu la crise
sanitaire et social et que à chaque fois
on se dit tiens on va profiter des de
sortir de ces moments difficiles pour
changer profondément notre schéma de
société la façon dont on fonctionne et
que quelque part naturellement il ya un
petit peu le comme on dit les habitudes
qui reviennent au galop qui s'installe
un petit peu et donc bah forcément parra
pour répondre plus précisément à la
question précédente on parle que
toujours que de ce visage des
difficultés des jeunes de banlieue de
d'insécurité de d'agressivité mais il
existe il sait des réalités dont il faut
absolument prendre compte mais aussi
plein d'autres choses qui se font et on
a aussi besoin pour que les habitants de
ces territoires se disent mathien je
suis pas ça comme une fatalité ou que je
suis pas aussi on a du potentiel sur nos
territoires il faut il faut peut-être
mieux montrer et les jeunes aujourd'hui
ils ont besoin d'avoir confiance en deux
et tant qu'on le reverra tout le temps
et moi j'ai vécu ça quand j'étais jeune
que je pourrais pas j'y arriverais pas
parce que je suis jeune parce que je
m'appelle zahia parce que je suis une
femme parce que je veux accéder à des
univers qui sont ceux de l'excellence de
la beauté de la réussite battant qu'on
reverra ça aux jeunes forcément ça sera
difficile aussi de leur faire changer
les choses et d'avoir envie d'aspirer à
des grandes ambitions il faut leur dire
que c'est possible et c'est ce que vous
faites une dernière question zahia
ziouani en lien avec notre lieu ce dôme
tournon du sénat on est entouré de
quatre statues qui représentent chacune
une vertu la sagesse ici la prudence la
justice est derrière moi l'éloquence est
ce qu'il ya une de ses vertus qui vous
caractérise plus que les autres à bien
écouter
j'aime à croire que mon travail cinq
heures dans ses cales verte' mais en
tout cas où est peut-être moins la
justice et celle que qui me touche le
plus parce qu'il faut en choisir une
demande et dans celle exercée voilà mais
cette notion de justice justement sûr
d'avoir d'avoir un traitement juste et
il ya une envie pour que tout le monde
réussisse qu'on est tous les mêmes
réussite et je trouve cette notion de
justice elle doit justement s'incarner
dans voilà dans tellement de domaines
différents et donc on a franchement on
peut être que fier de vivre dans notre
pays et franchement aujourd'hui j'ai pas
envie d'aller habiter ailleurs qu'en
france mais voilà on doit on peut plus
faire semblant de vivre encore dans un
schéma qui appartient au xxème siècle au
19e siècle et on doit complètement
réinterroger aussi notre schéma de
société sur l'éducation l'accès au sport
l'accès à la culture sur un certain
nombre d'aspects et
j'espère que ma contribution permettra
de faire un peu avancer le sujet est
aujourd'hui de faire aussi en sorte que
les élus locaux les personnes du monde
économique du monde les travailleurs
sociaux les services de l'état en france
ça doit pas être des sujets sur lesquels
chacun travaille dans son coin on doit
travailler ensemble et ça on se semble
en ce sens aussi je pense qu'on doit
faire et évoluer nos pratiques et et
j'espère que les parlementaires voilà
qui travaillent voilà enfin les jeux
c'est qu'ils oeuvrent aussi activement
là dessus mais prendront aussi
conscience que maintenant il faut qu'on
fasse mieux les choses ensemble message
est envoyé le message est passé vous
êtes au bon endroit merci infiniment
zahia ziouani d'avoir été avec nous dans
un monde un regard et on va se quitter
une fois n'est pas coutume sur du
tchaïkovski c'est votre venue qui nous
inspirait merci infiniment on se
retrouve très vite sur public sénat très
bientôt
attentes
[Musique]